Furqan Hello
[Music]
Great
People
Started Thoughts Anki Work Audio
Science Mein
Today We Will Read Bio And Physics
What Is D Formula
[Laughter]
S Fast Fast [
Music]
Code For Today Let's See Are
You Going To Respond To
Farish Aapme Session Mein Ho  There is no question of right session and
not and not is not the question right I should see you
every let me see in of you are there yes yes let's go
there
right
question
and the first question we will get started
nine right
this is not the time start
It is concave Focal length is going to be
negative So anything will be concave Concave
mirror can also be Concave lens will also be there
Whenever mines will happen It mines which so both of them should be
concave Right then this will be
negative
C D Leader  What does the board say? Let's see our
leaderboard now.
Physics and D. Best no problem about it
and culture. Fantastic let's get started. Goes ready
of D. Following substance. The
time for all questions is 30 seconds.
Box is there? Sir ji, don't answer in the chat box.
Okay.  Hai ho is
dat possible sir but
sweet port is cute sam come on gaze given
top fight
on d leader board very good very good
temperature recess
region d universe of d conductivity let's
see yaar [praise] temperature is visible to you temperature
formula correct
leader  Board
[laughter] It's
fun man good
evening
photo
ok he is saying
no what to do now right but
children have answered
yes fantastic gas fantastic let's
sit board will not happen
right nine please get in tomorrow we had a session
Saw that if you have joined even late then
rate steel you are able to get in d
leaderboard or real POS there d cool dude was there
right so please get and get
in fast
this is yours
so less time
CBSE board examination is known from here only
No problem, we will have to
restart, right
[Music]
76 out of 80
Chemistry
Ready Join everyone join in
Half of D Class
Teacher Conglomeration is
needed
No problem,
we will do more sessions Now only there is time for our
exam
Science 4th March Right D  Time
and Bunty is on the top, what's the matter? Bunty
Sagar is there, there is the
sky,
okay,
how does the story go, the sky comes up, let's
see,
so very good, very good, change your name,
go, I will also change your name  I will take it okay,
change the name to A, go ₹50, it will
sound better,
then do A, go, we will also enjoy, you will also enjoy,
red good job,
this van is going to you, I have a physics question, I am
gas, we will
have a physics question.
What difference does it make, friend, for you
science is everything, everything has to be studied,
come on, I went
wrong here my child, there are
many rights,
come on, you did it right,
in this both session and reason are
correct but the reason is not correct.
Rishika has a fantastic culture,
now bio will come sir [
laughter]
He is catching and going well,
so it has an application, that is, the new solar panels being made these days, correct yes,
because of bio physics, it
is also a very applied application, that is a
complete field.  Off Bio Physics
Magic I Come on let's
solve the physics question quickly let's
see what people do now
remember
magnetic field lines d more wood b d
strength close respect magnetic field lines
d less of wood b d strength magnetic
field strength is d  Say everyone,
none of this is an option boss, it is easy, what else did you
use directly?
Look, I also know bio physics sir, I am
still remembering some correct from 10th
because
he tells what is the density of the magnetic field line.  We need the
strength of the magnetic field, which has the
highest density near the pole.
Option A is the correct right. Let's be
absolutely
right. Over every witch is a new name in this particulars.
Welcome, you are the leader board. Welcome. Gas, welcome.
Where did we go?
Question number six,
not
one, friend.  So what do you call it a minute, you give it
D Answer Very good
for D first time Very good So what is its answer Its
right side naps this D Correct answer for
date C What happens in miss If there are
neurotransmitters, then electrical
impulses will come on dendritic ends  The
dendritic end will release the neuro transmitter. The
neuro transmitter will be received by the
dendritic end of the D inside the
axis and then it will convert into the electrical campus.
So this date is the D story.
Electricals on D finger tips
explains the whole thing from the fingertips. Write it, friend,
tomorrow.  You see,
what's the matter in that, it's okay,
still a go friend joint joint joint
2955236 this D code
magnet moving charges electric current
battery seemed very conjuring to me
when I first came out on the question I am
not understanding.  What are you talking about
sir
for this
what does
not change again yes
sir right group was
last nine also there red come on come on come on
come on sit look at them
gone from here to here red very good gas very good good van
Let's see the next question.
What happens outside the brain that is controlled by the brain? The brain
knows how to do it.
Medulla
oblongata is a part of the brain.
Hypothalamus is a small thing. It
is also a part of the brain.
I don't know.  Now
Ponds Medulla, what is it, how have
you forgotten, never mind, it doesn't matter
which parts are there, I had told you about the
kite, I had told you how to make a kite, I had told you that I had
not told you how a kite is made, I had told you how to make a kite,
then how?  Forgot my child,
people are fine, it
affects you, so this date is your
region, now you are mine, what is the answer to this, if it
is not ponds, then son, what is the pause, where is the pause,
this is your pause,
rate ponds, whose is it, medulla oblongota, now
medulla.  oblongittak, which part
is that, its name is this, going forward, it becomes your
spinal cord, read the elongation of your
medulla oblongata, this is the final cord, so here,
which will be the correct answer, then breathing is controlled by
medulla, offline data, hypothalamus, I
told you the trick of this.  H is for hunger H is
for hypothalamus rate So
your hypothalamus controls hunger Read it You have
Serena told you I have told you what does the ball do
rate and this is it brown majority
of d job of your thinking creativity
language everything is a major part of your brain
So that is what reduces the right, I want to tell everyone one thing,
if you want to make any diagram,
especially related bio, then give it in this
series by Devika, I go and what date,
so be it any diagram, you can make it within 1 minute,
I make it.  So
while making the diagram, you have to remember one thing,
make as many diagrams as possible in the bio, but while making the diagram,
make it accurate and do not make it very tight and neat, that is
why I have made all the
diagrams with just pencil and pen.
Sir, many times
children sit with their colorful pens, they
show a lot of creativity. Now is there
any extra mark of creativity, is it
necessary to be labelled?
I see so many things, Sir, I
see in them that I have made a diagram of a heart
outside.  You have made the inside red, you have to make it green, you have to
shade the
pressure
diagram. How ever you make it, labeling is very
important and you will have to do a little scale in physics,
you have to make all the diagrams by measuring the proper distance, this is a very
important tip.  Very important
tips, it is not that one wire is made long and
one wire is made short
[laughter]
Hello
and question, put it on your screen,
this is the second circuit of MBBS guy Munna Bhai,
actually his name was inspired from here,
okay he had more.
[Laughter]
[Music]
What is a short circuit? So what is a short
circuit? Remember, there are two wires in it. Which are the
two? One is
its live wire and the other is
neutral. Is there
any resistance in between the virus?
Sometimes it happens that two
wires will be connected, then when these two wires are
connected, all the current is from the
live neutral wire, so suddenly
a lot of current goes inside the neutral wire
because as told in our Holmes R = V /  I have
n't and you can right I make it equal, what will
happen, the current will be infinity, meaning the current will
increase a lot,
people are reading well, it means you are
understanding the gas is going in the right
direction, son,
I am fine right now.
Ananya Saxena
[laughs] Those thoughts are also there,
not completely wrong,
but when we move ahead, you will come to
know that
how can I join the memory class, so I have some solutions,
my thinking is correct, no sir.
Thinking is D Major job of your thinking
every dim time You are thinking You are working You are thinking Consciously
Subconsciously Your
sleeping Your thinking so it will
continue its 24/7 Its thinking is low rate so
thoughts D Correct answer for date This
ring and function  The witch part is
our temporal lobes, don't you
remember the lobes, you people don't remember the
rate, the front is the low temporal loop, the
temporal lobes are always above the tick on the ears,
always remember this, we
learn like this.  It is okay that if it stays above the ear band
then if it sits below the ear then where will it go, if there is any
savings in the right temples,
then date it and place it
near the ear, they also remain right and the
rejections of URI still remain.  Whatever is
lacking in vision is done by Asif people. This is how I
do it.
All the girls get inspired. So if
you want to go,
you should go to Infinity Learn website and check what are the
different courses available if you want to just go.
Through dam you can just
join, isn't it Imran, I have already
explained it, okay,
we will finish a complete revision of it before our science paper,
okay son, so don't worry, the
entire chapter, we will revise it before the
science paper.  First of all,
we are the people who will not let you sit idle, otherwise we will make you do
less work and
do very intense revision. Okay, those who are going to appear
in the exam, I will make you revise such topics,
so don't worry.
Revising our brain is very important.
Advise, what is that?  It does all this garbage for
us, it puts it all in the conscious mind, it is
very important to keep it in the current folder,
thank you so much
[praise]
11th, we have to
start it, now you focus on the board, let us get
bored, then we will definitely do it 27  On
March we will tell them what to do in 11th,
okay, which subject
should you do, what should be your choice,
remove such thoughts from your mind till 27th March, on 27th
March you will have your best month's paper, it
is okay to have less day, all tenths.  Chapter Van
will open a new chapter and the remaining thing is to
join Sir's classes.
In the description box below you have been given the
call Infinity lawn.com. Just go
click on Airtel D Classes.
Confused
or Towards West North East West
South news.
Now see what.
Okay, now I understand the question, you know the
current flying in the electricity line towards
North, so if you know the direction, then the direction,
now I draw here,
this direction going inside date is
not North, if this is then
who is on your side?  C will come to the south, right? And
which one will go to my side? East? Which one to my side will come to the
west? You take North in the center. Do
you know that whenever you
look at the board, this is North and this is out.
Correct this is this.
West is what we write on the board, so
write this on this paper and 4 it's paper like this, so
inside the man's side, East on my side, West on
your side, South, so what is the current given now,
it is going in the direction of North,
so the electric current is in  D. Direction
of North, then which rule will you use for that? Right
hand thumb rule and left hand rule.
So we have to find out the direction of the magnetic field. The direction rule of the
magnetic field has been divided.
Correct answer is nice.
Answer the question. Which thumb
rule will you use first?  Will you do it left or right or right?
You are going to use right hand thumb rule
because there is no force here, right,
when force comes, then you will go to left hand,
if there is no force, it is
day time, if there is no force, it is only
current and magnetic.  Let the field c him d
right hand thumb rule so there right hand thumb rule I hole
d conductor in my right hand
so thumb tell me d direction of current and this finger which is
curling around they will tell
me d direction of magnetic field
so now I  As told this is the
direction of current going in D page region
not and here what is given just below so
this is the direction of current below this where will
be the magnetic field in this region then
this is the finger which is from the bottom side I have placed
side A  From above it is going towards I. From
below it is towards me. So
which direction is my side? It is
West. If asked above then it would be
East and below it would be West so date is the
same this is this.  Correct,
tell only one team, they have right hand and
left hand is
simple, it has to be other pen, pencil, whatever, whatever is
holding in your hand, if your right hand
is the thumb, it will tell you the right hand of
current, rotate it in any direction, right?
Also you need in the direction
What is left hand FB Aye F given let's see
you Federal Bureau of Investigation F means
force Aye means current sorry B means
magnetic field and I mean current Fb aye
thumb is D force first finger magnetic
field second finger current task right  Let's
see the leaderboard right now
son
5 2 3 6 end d leader board
what's the matter
[laughter]
Jethalal rocking witch
of d following group of organs isms outside
d body and
give absorbed external digestion then
it is eaten
nothing to do outside  Just do everything and then
take it inside.
Question Nice Vishnu, let's see Vishnu, can you solve it
[laughter]
These are all parasites, right, if you leave the amoeba,
then it will be like this in the amoeba. If asked if
amoeba comes from history, then man brother,
historical is also a parasite.  If there is a rate,
then the parasite goes inside and eats your blood. It
pierces the same plate. I
always tell you the example of a parasite, so
this is the correct one, which is a fungus, which is
your yeast, which is your mushroom, if rate is bread mods, then
this is  What do all of them do?
Enzymes are released outside, digestion takes place and then they are
absorbed and it's a
little about please let's see
Rishika Bunty Jethalal
and question number 13,
we, this is
not coaching, it will either be
black or red or
When I was young, I
always used to think, why don't birds stick to it? I always used to
think that
if something sticks, there must
be a potential difference. When they
sit, there is no potential difference between their two legs. Thoughts have it that
birds
don't stick to
each other.
Motivating people are coming out,
what is there
ahead of me sir
[music]
air, after this you see the conductor of electricity,
then
what is air between them and what is air, what is bed conductor,
bar conductor means one wire
will carry current in the other wire.  Otherwise,
we do not need insulation, so date is the same, it is the
correct arms option, I will tell the rest of the answers,
air is not affected by
gravity, here gravity has nothing to do with
electricity, magnetism,
give current, current rating is  High
or current rating has nothing to do with
insulation and current
running. What is completely different current rating? Sir,
four star, three star, five star
fuse comes in fuse which is either 5
MP current rating or 10 MP current rating.
And electric three flows very
fast and will
go
right now, you are Payal Sagar four soap right
and Han is only one girl, she has three boys,
boys power boys,
now picky, nice, nice, great, let's
show it, go all the way, Rishika, Haj, Sam,
want you  Tu b aate d top butt
screen gas let's
see are this pudding question yr
dislibraing in saliva which of d following
event in d mouth cavity will be affected
starts breaking down in sir protein
breaking down in amino acid facts in
fatty acid absorption of vitamin will  It did not
happen,
Jai Shri, you also come here,
you join a little in the middle, I do
n't know the date right, so I will not have protein background, there is
no Pepsi, there is pepsin, there is
acid in the mouth in acidic condition.  Talking about
mileage, talking about
salivary amylage,
amylage will always work on stars, you
convert it into simple form here,
what is the simmer form, our malts are there here, then it will
go inside, then it will go into the stomach,
from the stomach, then it will go into the small intestine.  There, there,
pancreati mileage,
come on it, it will come down,
why did it go
wrong Rishika, let's see [
laughter]
so I'll see who knows,
let's keep going physics physics
okay [
laughter]
fight
okay
Rishi  Ka Jethalal
or OK Next Question Sir Next
Question
Physics should have come now Sir Han Physics should have
come now no which is
not good will go
wrong
[Praise]
We have arranged these in parallel so this is
this R
What is the value of this R 100/  3 So nine if
three resistances are in parallel and all three have
equal value then what will be R parallel
wood b R / 3 is right
na
correct then what will be the value of R what is
100 / 3 / 3
witch c hoon tha easy tha yaar do
n't do wrong
[Laughter] You had
given the correct answer, Right, you
will bring the good maths sir to the hall, won't you make the maths sir
happy, he has given full 5 hours of maths in your head,
sir, get out
right, let's
see whose soap is slow and whose
is fast, Bunty's.  How is soap
[laughter]
[music]
Well, the last
system is
understood from the immune system,
but many times children do
not know about the system. It is
important to know about the right immune system that it
damages our IMU system.  We also get
UV rays rights because those who are our sales are very
sensitive
Hema Congress All of you All Video Gas All
of you Whose points are there, what are the points, let's do it from
Monday onwards,
definitely see how many points are there while
solving the sample question papers.  Stay
rate and on date Note M Devika and Akash Take your leave
So Sagar Sunday Practice
as much as possible See you back on Monday Let's have
a lot of fun What's the matter Then
actually this happens with time
but I want 100% accuracy  Whose
answers are all correct? Right date is important. Bye see
you everyone.